so mine suck [ __ ] at 99.9% of the things
in the world and that's like a fun thing
to giggle at but it's actually
shockingly true
I was a UH I was a solid at the students
in school and then of marketing like I
think when I tell people that I was a
DNF student people laughed like haha
because they've had success and they
think I mean B's and C's don't mean like
these nets right I was really bad at
school mainly because this time I can
remember which is three I've always
wanted to sell stuff right and I'm a
businessman through and through and I
think about why have I been able to be
successful even though everything that
led up to let's say when I was 18 years
old
on paper traditionally the way we score
let itself to make people believe that I
wasn't going to be successful and then
started thinking about the world we live
in a very start thinking about wow you
know I'm living a one-percent life I'm
financially ridiculously secure I'm I'm
right now focused on buying New York
Jets
right so literally I'm trying to become
a billionaire I've got all these great
things and why am I sitting back there
and willing to give up everything that
I've achieved over the last 20 years of
call it to trade places with any one of
the people in this room and I was think
about why is that and why is that really
true
and I'm not proud of like giving you
like [ __ ] oh I'm sure with you like
I really mean it and the reason is
because what I realized was holy crap we
live in the most ridiculous ridiculous
era of all times this is what I mean the
cost the infrastructural cost to do what
you want to do marina life has collapsed
over the last 10 years there's this
thing that you guys heard about it you
may want to write this down there's a
thing called the internet right and it's
something that wasn't important or
really at scale when I was your age only
15 years ago right and you know really
the internet took off in the US when in
Windows 95 came out and so it's really
only been about 17 years that the
Internet has been a consumer facing
product and only really over the last
five to ten at scale what the Internet
has done not Facebook or Twitter or
tumblr or Pinterest or Instagram or
snapchat but the Internet itself has
done is created a scenario where there's
really little to no reason unless you're
not just obsessed with the organization
and more person during the rest of the
thing today I think you have this
seriously debate where you are in your
life right now and give enormous thought
to try to make the thing that you love
the most in the world work for you
you